on your knees
okay chop it off chop it off let's do it
[Music]
oh we got him now
you know what I'm thinking they're
probably sharper stairs somewhere else
we're thieves but we helped the wrong
person steal the wrong thing and unleash
the greatest evil the world has ever
known
the red Wizards created an army of the
undead
sounds lovely quite the opposite I know
I was being ironic I find irony as a
player because he who wields it most
especially you're not a lot of fun are
you
how are we gonna pull this off we're
gonna need a team
[Applause]
follow me it's the orifice
the orifice
I'll go lost
I don't mind that
he missed
no that's not good
sick of failing we could die there's
worse things than dying
I lost everything that ever mattered to
me and if we quit now that's for nothing
I don't want to see you die which is why
I'm Gonna Leave the Room
discounts now
the bridge is protected by an ancient
trap we must not trigger the mechanism
I may have triggered the mechanism
so
sorry
[Music]